[Música]
avanza el conteo de las elecciones de
medio término en Estados Unidos con una
cerrada batalla por el senado y con los
republicanos avanzando para tomar el
control de la cámara de representantes
byden afirmó que fue una buena jornada
para la democracia mientras que Donald
Trump aseguró que no fue una buena
jornada para los republicanos
las fuerzas armadas de Brasil entregaron
al tribunal superior electoral un
informe sobre el uso de las urnas
electrónicas en las elecciones
presidenciales los primeros indicios
apuntan a que no hubo ningún tipo de
fraude en la elección de Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva quien tuvo su primer
evento político oficial tras ser elegido
llegó a Caracas la capital venezolana el
primer avión de una aerolínea colombiana
con este vuelo los países vecinos dan un
paso más en la reanudación de las
relaciones diplomáticas y comerciales a
través de las conexiones aéreas
Bienvenidos a una nueva informativo de
France 24 Mi nombre es Rodrigo sedano y
es un gusto acompañarles abrimos esta
emisión en Estados Unidos en donde sigue
el recuento de votos luego de las
elecciones de medio término al hilo de
los resultados ya conocidos mejores de
lo esperado para los demócratas el
presidente Joe byden afirmó que fue una
buena jornada para la democracia y abrió
la posibilidad de una candidatura en
2024 para su reelección sobre los
resultados se pronunció también el ex
presidente Donald Trump en sus redes
sociales Truth en su mensaje reconoció
la sensación general de que no han sido
unos buenos resultados para el partido
republicano si bien aseguró que sí lo
fueron en el ámbito personal
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos hablaba
sobre el estado de Georgia que podría
volver a ser clave en el control del
senado
clave clave y de hecho va a ser según
analistas y muchos aquí en Washington
están diciendo será en Georgia donde se
defina precisamente la mayoría en el
congreso nuevamente hace dos años se
definió también ahí en un desempate
también entre Rafael worlock y la otra
candidata republicana y en esta elección
también Warner que estará presente en un
desempate que pues se conocerá el 6 de
diciembre es decir hay que esperar casi
que un mes más para saber qué partido va
a quedarse con la mayoría en en el
senado en la cámara alta y lo que la
razón por la cual esto ocurre es porque
pues aunque Georgia en el pasado era
considerado un estado republicano pues
recientemente ciudades como Atlanta pues
han empezado a jugar un rol bastante
importante el núcleos urbanos están
tildando más hacia el partido de la
población joven está votando mucho más
hacia el partido demócrata y la
población inmigrante también se ha
tildado más hacia el partido demócrate
esto ha hecho que los centros urbanos a
gran contrapeso a esa mayoría roja
mayoría republicana que normalmente
tenía Georgia y está forzando
precisamente a estos desempates es
importante Resaltar entonces que pues lo
decía antes los demócratas quieren
tienen que asegurar dos sillas una sería
la de Nevada y otra la de Georgia para
asegurar la mayoría en el senado y pues
los republicanos tendrían que ganar
Georgia y quedarse con Arizona también
para lograr esa mayoría
nos vamos hasta Brasil en donde las
fuerzas armadas se entregaron al
tribunal superior electoral el informe
sobre las urnas electrónicas usadas
durante las elecciones presidenciales
los primeros indicios apuntan a que no
hay evidencia de manipulación o fraude
en los comicios que dieron como ganador
a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el
mandatario elector se reunió con el
presidente de la cámara de diputados
también con el presidente del senado y
estamentos de Justicia del país Con
quienes conversó sobre formas para
retomar la institucionalidad y el
diálogo entre poderes entre tanto
continúan las protestas de simpatizantes
del presidente bolsonaro en rechazo a
los resultados de los comicios Valeria
sacone nos cuenta más detalles desde Río
de Janeiro
hace una semana Seguidores del
presidente ayer revolucionario están
acampados en el centro de Río de Janeiro
enfrente del cuartel general del
ejército protestan contra la victoria de
Luis Ignacio libro da Silva y las
elecciones del 30 de octubre y dicen que
hubo fraude a pesar de que no hay
pruebas
sí dato aquí robaron 6 millones de votos
de nuestro candidato que es Yair
bolsonaro Mi voto no fue computado Pero
cuál es la prueba hay pruebas los
militares hicieron una auditoría y están
averiguando si hubo fraude solo el
presidente del tribunal superior
electoral no quiso ver estas pruebas
si la fuerzas armadas no encuentran
ningún indicio de fraude Creo que vale
la pena también Escuchar La voluntad del
pueblo
al final de cuentas vivimos en una
democracia y estamos manifestando
nuestro derecho de hablar de Buscar
pruebas lo que no aceptamos es este
sistema de gobierno en entonces solo nos
quedan las fuerzas armadas
no vamos a salir de aquí puede llover
puede pasar lo que sea vamos a
permanecer firmes aquí hasta que nos
esclarezca todo eso
ese es el campamento donde desde hace
una semana los manifestantes duermen
comen y cenan no hay fecha para irse
dicen que se van a quedar hasta que el
último corrupto de Brasil se ha
expulsado porque su lucha dicen es una
lucha popular contra la corrupción
con la llegada del primer vuelo de una
aerolínea colombiana a la ciudad de
Caracas procedente de Bogotá Colombia y
Venezuela dan un paso más en la
reanudación de las relaciones
diplomáticas y comerciales a través de
las conexiones aéreas que reducirán
considerablemente los tiempos de viaje
entre ambos países y facilitará el
intercambio de bienes
Colombia y Venezuela más cerca este
miércoles llegó a Caracas el primer
vuelo desde Bogotá después de casi tres
años sin conexión directa el gobierno de
maduro lo celebra
bueno primeramente hoy celebramos la
victoria de nuestros presidentes
presidente Petro por Colombia el
presidente Nicolás maduro con la
República bolivariana de Venezuela ya
que estamos formalizando la conectividad
aérea entre dos grandes pueblos hermanos
Colombia y Venezuela hermandado como lo
soñaron nuestros Libertadores el vuelo
lo operó la aerolínea Estatal colombiana
satena del presidente Gustavo Petro
quiere fortalecerla
por primera vez ministro por primera vez
en la historia hace un vuelo
internacional y no cualquier vuelo no a
la Florida no aruba lo hizo a
restablecer la hermandad entre Colombia
y Venezuela el lunes había despegado el
primer vuelo fue en la conexión inversa
de Caracas a Bogotá la compañía
venezolana que lo operó fue turpial
propiedad de un Coronel retirado de la
fuerza aérea venezolana esto debido a
que la estatal venezolana conviasa no
Pudo realizar el vuelo por las sanciones
financieras de Estados Unidos pero algo
parece estar cambiando en el mundo Cómo
se vio en la cop 27 Nicolás Maduro
presidente de Venezuela vuelve a ser
contactado por otros jefes de estado
como Gustavo Petro presidente de
Colombia quien ya le había visitado en
Caracas y ha sido impulsor desde su toma
de Posesión en agosto del
restablecimiento de relaciones entre los
dos países así como de la reapertura de
fronteras
cerramos este informativo con la noticia
de la muerte de la cantante gal Costa
uno de los símbolos más grandes de la
música brasileña Costa falleció este
miércoles a los 77 años por razones aún
no confirmadas la artista quien se
convirtió en una de las figuras más
icónicas de la música popular del país
tuvo 50 años de carrera en los que se
transformó en un ejemplo revolucionario
para sus colegas
el ámbito cultural de Brasil está de
luto el fallecimiento de la cantante gal
Costa a sus 77 años una de las mejores
voces que surgieron de tierra brasileña
estremeció al mundo artístico y generó
el pesar de sus ciudadanos
gal Costa fue una de las más grandes
cantantes del mundo una de nuestras
principales artistas para llevar el
nombre y los sonidos de Brasil a todo el
planeta su talento técnica y audacia
enriquecieron y renovaron nuestra
cultura formaron y marcaron la vida de
millones de brasileños
la llamada musa del tropicalismo no
solamente fue uno de los pilares de la
música popular brasileña durante su
trayectoria enfrentó al conservadurismo
a la dictadura militar convirtiéndose en
referente para sus colegas
rompió todos los paradigmas todas las
fronteras rompió las barreras
para mi Generación fue la más
Revolucionaria de las cantantes
rompió la falsedad rompió patrones
rompió todo eso Gael siempre fue la gran
Revolución no sé cómo expresar mis
sentimientos Estoy impactada por la
noticia
[Música]
nacida en Salvador en 1945 comenzó su
carrera a los 15 años tras conocer a
otro símbolo de Brasil caetano veloso
después de 50 años gay Costa pasará del
estrellato a la posteridad de Brasil
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]